(calm music)
- John Heilbron is a great gardener.
Now this is an aspect of John's life
that not everyone knows about,
but I see in this audience
a handful of people who,
like myself, have visited
John and his wife,
Allison Browning, in their
home in the Cotswolds
behind which is a huge
and impeccably maintained English garden.
And the two of them do it themselves.
I mention this because it's an example
of talents and accomplishments
not on the public record that assist
in making John Heilbron
one of the most universally talented,
accomplished, and prodigiously
energetic people that I know.
Now, John is especially known
for two themes in his
life that were addressed
by our colleague Bill Lester yesterday
in introducing John.
One, his eminence as a
historian of science,
his eminence as a scholar, his
achievements as a historian
that have earned him a place on the list
of distinguished names that
we find in our program.
A second thing Bill mentioned
that I want to underscore
is John's long-standing
connection to Berkeley.
Bill mentioned that John had
been chair of the senate here,
had been vice chancellor,
had founded our Office
for the History of Science and Technology.
Indeed John has had a long term
and a deeply devoted
relationship to UC Berkeley,
comes back often, and those of us
that work in OHST have brought him back
as an emeritus professor a number of times
and greatly enriched by his presence,
especially the advice that he offers
to many of us about academic
and administrative issues.
One aspect of John's
connection to Berkeley,
which I think has largely been forgotten,
although some of you here who
have been around the longest
may be aware of it is that John was,
as a graduate student,
a doctoral student here
of Thomas S. Kuhn.
So he's been involved with distinguished
intellectual activities on
this campus for a long time,
and I want to comment that
when Tom Kuhn died in the '90s,
John wrote an exceptionally
beautiful and thoughtful
memorial essay to Tom
in which he described
the structure of scientific revolutions
as holding to the history
and philosophy of science,
a relation somewhat like
an impressionist painting
to the history of painting
which is to say that with the structure
of scientific revolution,
you don't get a lot of close up
technical detail that you can measure
but you do get an impression about
the object of perception
that's really different.
It changes your understanding of it,
a great memorial essay about Tom Kuhn.
I want also to observe that
when John was Vice Chancellor here,
among his many accomplishments
is not well known
outside of administrative circles,
and that is that he convened a competition
among deans and chairs
as to who could write
the most terse administrative memos.
And John always won the competition.
So we have before us
then a great gardener,
a great memorialist,
a great administrator,
a great teacher, and quite simply
the best historian of science
in the English speaking
world, John Heilbron.
(crowd applauding)
- Well, in in order that you can calibrate
these very kind remarks by David,
I must tell you that my
garden is full of weeds.
(audience laughing)
Yesterday I exhibited certain parallels
between the physical and
the historical sciences
in the early modern period.
I begin today with examples
of the application of physics to history
and of causes to both
and proceed to their joint attack
on the old space timeframe.
I end with applications to the
contemporary Berkeley scene.
Here is what we're going to do today.
You can keep track of my progress
by remembering the numbers.
So, first, to historico-mathematics.
Jean Mabillon, whom you'll
remember from last time
as the codifier of the
ancillary historical sciences
like to repeat the classical slogan
that geography and chronology
are the two eyes of history.
Many savants of the late
17th and early 18th century
brought these two disciplines
and knowledge of old languages to bare
on ancient history both
sacred and profane.
The result was an arresting antiquarianism
that, in order to keep
my accounts in parallel,
I'll call historico-mathematics.
Newton was its most
dedicated practitioner.
Another was Olof Rudbeck, the elder,
Professor of Medicine at
the University of Uppsala,
a distinguished anatomist and botanist
and the discoverer of
the lymphatic system.
Here he shows himself
practicing his anatomical art
on the Eye of Geography.
On his right, acting as his
ostensor or demonstrator
is history's other eye in
the head of Father Time.
They performed before sages,
arranged as if in an anatomical theater.
On Time's right, Hesiod,
Plato, and Aristotle.
On Rudbeck's left, Orpheus,
Homer, blindly looking
through a telescope, and Plutarch.
In the foreground with their backs to us,
Apollodorus, Tacitus, and Odysseus.
And in the lower right
corner, a perplexed Ptolemy,
the astronomer and geographer,
apparently questioning the
value of his instruments.
These gentlemen are witnesses
both to ancient knowledge
and to Rudbeck's great discovery
which all of them had missed,
that the island of
Atlantis was safe and well
and known in the modern world as Sweden.
(audience laughing)
Now the proposition is fairly obvious
when you compare as Rudbeck did
the geography of Atlantis
as described by Plato
with the physical features of Sweden.
No place on Earth better resembles
the capital of Atlantis than Uppsala.
Consideration of runes
and old Swedish calendars
and the names and doings of Norse gods
indicated that writing, astronomy,
and mythology, yay civilization itself
originated in the north from whence
precocious vikings brought
it to Greece and Egypt
a century or two after the flood.
I can't rehearse for you the 2,000 pages
of ingenious arguments
rich with wild etymologies,
correspondences and
geography and chronology
and identifications of
personages in classical mythology
with their Swedish originals with which
Rudbeck clinched his case.
But the slide gives a
little symbolic guidance.
Rudbeck draws back a flap of Earth flesh
marked Svíþjóð or Sweden to reveal bedrock
labeled diorem insula,
the island of the gods,
the birthplace of Saturn and
his dysfunctional family.
Above the scene the great and little bears
and the polestar symbolize the north
and the astronomical knowledge
needed to solve historical problems.
And underneath it all is the concession
that Rudbeck and his audience are men,
for the words et nos homines
signify, as he explains
1,000 pages on, that
all of us make mistakes.
Several of Rudbeck's
learned contemporaries
applauded his "Atlantica",
and a few as learned as he
in science and history
wrote similar extravagances.
Still, most people who cultivated
the historical sciences around 1700
would've taken the slogan
'All of us make mistakes'
to be the only useful truth
in Rudbeck's huge book.
Isaac Newton's first published work
was an edition of a book on geography.
His last work, published
posthumously, was on chronology.
Still he did not have
20/20 historical vision.
He accepted Bishop
Ussher's dating of creation
at 4,000 years before Christ,
and the Old Testament
as a reliable account
of human history.
This tight timeframe
had the standard problem
that it could not accommodate
the extensive pedigrees
claimed by the Babylonians,
the Chinese, and the Egyptians,
or the special problem Newton took
as his personal historical assignment.
This was to show that the usual dating
of ancient history which
gave the Greeks seniority
over the Hebrews in the invention
of the arts and sciences was wrong.
He labored incessantly to solve it.
Here is one page of his notes
on his reading of ancient history
which you see is written
in any different direction
on an invitation from somebody else
to something he didn't go to.
To his literal mind, the headstart
of the old Hebrews and
their easy access to God
should've made them the teachers
of mankind in all things.
Consequently, despite the evidence,
Solomon's age must have preceded
the high civilization of Troy.
Ussher dated Solomon at
3,000 years after creation
or 1,000 BC.
Hence, Achilles and
the other Greek heroes,
whom Newton accepted as
historical characters,
must have lived in the first
millennium before Christ.
Newton's method of
demonstrating this conclusion
may be followed most readily
on this simulacrum of the heavens,
the Farnese Globe, an artifact
of the second century AD.
It represents the constellations
much as the Greek Poet
Aratus described him
around 350 BC, that is 500 years earlier.
Aratus had his information
from the now lost
writings of Eudoxus who
lived at the time of Plato.
Have you got that?
This is all secure.
The next step is not.
Newton supposed that the descriptions
of Aratus and Eudoxus
were authentic records
from the time of the invention,
not the depiction, but the
invention of the constellation.
When was that?
According to Eudoxus, the
most ancient astronomers
placed the equinoxes in the centers
of the Ram and the Balance.
By the time of Ptolemy, however,
when the globe was made in 150 AD,
the equinoctial colure,
which is the great circle
that passes through the equinoxes
in the North and South
poles of the heavens,
ran as you can see through
the horn of the Ram.
Using the rate of this displacement
from the middle of the Ram to his horn
of the equinoctial colure,
Newton calculated from
his gravitational theory
and Aratus' description
of the constellations
that the poet had portrayed the heavens
as they appeared in 950 BC.
Newton had only to associate this date
with an episode in Greek history
that might've required marking out
constellations on a sphere.
The voyage of the Argonauts
was just the thing.
Tradition reported that Chiron the Centaur
had taught Jason the use of the sphere
to find his way to the golden fleece.
Now, Jason turned out to be a very poor
student of navigation.
On his homeward journey, he allowed
the good ship Argos to wander
all over Northern Europe,
even onto Sweden, according to Rudbeck.
Rudbeck made his students carry models
of the ship as he imagined it
over long distances to
show that Jason's men
could've made the necessary traverse
between rivers in Russia.
Being of Swedish descent, you recall,
they're Greeks.
Being of Swedish descent, the Argonauts
would've been as strong and
tough as Uppsala students.
By placing Chiron's lecture's on astronomy
50 years after Solomon flourished,
Newton made it possible for the centaurs
to have learned their
science from the Jews.
At the high cost, however, of knocking
three centuries out of Greek history
as understood by Newton's contemporaries
and confirmed by ancient inscriptions.
Francesco Bianchini who
made the first analysis
of the Farnese Globe reasoned,
there he is reasoning,
looking through his telescope,
reasoned independently of Newton
to date the first celestial sphere
to the time of the Argonauts.
By taking literally the scale
inscribed upon the globe,
Bianchini obtained 1,275
BC as the likely date
of the launching of the Argo.
He probably told Newton
about his calculation
but the great man would
not accept the date
that agreed with everything else
known about Greek history.
Now, it turns out that
the best modern date
for the sack of Homer's Troy
agrees perfectly with Bianchini's
date for the Argonauts
who, had they existed, would've done so
a generation before Priam and Agamemnon.
Incidentally you saw Bianchini yesterday
at a sale of ancient coins.
I'll let you fine pick out which he is.
He was an important
historian and archeologist
as well as an astronomer,
a perfect physico-historico mathematician.
Newton was virtually the dictator
of the Royal Society of London
for a quarter century
before his death in 1727.
His authority and achievement will explain
why over half the members of the society
who responded to a questionnaire
about their interest in 1718 replied
either physico-mathematics
or antiquities, or both,
whether or not they could do arithmetic
or decipher a Latin inscription.
In order to prolong his
dominance after his death,
Newton chose as his successor a young man
named Martin Folkes
who was enough of a mathematician
to understand the Principia
and an expert on old
coins, weights and medals.
Folkes did succeed Newton,
but not immediately.
In the meantime he went to Italy
where he saw the Farnese Globe
of which he made a replica and an exact
planospheric projection.
On his return to England
he exhibited his globe
to the Royal Society,
and the Royal Society of Antiquaries
which thus obtained the hardware
for correcting Newton's calculation.
While president of the Royal Society,
Folkes also served as
president of the Antiquaries.
His personal union of the two crowns
of British learning demonstrates
that the parallels I have been developing
on the level of ideas had a reflection
on the institutional plain.
The historico-mathematicians of the Paris
Académie des Inscriptions
delighted over Newton's
posthumous chronologies
of the ancient kingdoms amended.
At last the greatest man who ever lived,
as Newton's countrymen styled him,
had show himself a true John Bull.
Wrong, wrong, and stubbornly wrong.
I'll not trouble you with the many errors
lovingly cataloged by Nicolas Freret,
secretary of the Academy of Inscriptions,
who though he accepted
creation in 4,000 BC
could not credit the existence
of Chiron the Centaur
and refused to distort Greek history
to save the reputation of Solomon.
I say only that Freret's argument remained
within the restricted circle
of historico-mathematics.
The line from Newton to Freret
did not produce Voltaire
any more than the line
from Newton to Folkes
produced Gibbon.
Mixed mathematics did
not engender true history
any more than it did true physics.
That is because in both cases,
the philosophy, the causes, were left out.
I come to causes and motives.
The review of Newton's Principia
in the "Journal des
sçavans" was not ecstatic.
It's a good piece of
mathematics, the reviewers said,
but garbage as physics,
for physics is a science of causes
as in the pushy universe of Descartes,
and Newton expressly forswore
specifying hypotheses,
that is physical causes.
But as the 18th century wore on,
natural philosophers lost their scruples
against admitting such
absurdities as distant forces,
and repopulated the bare and Cartesian
mechanistic world with special substances
like electrical and magnetic fluids,
the matter of heat and light,
the matter of heat and fire
and particles of light.
And they calculated, as if they believed
in gravitational and electrical forces
that act at a distance.
They restrained their
joined imagination, however,
by subjecting it to the control
of systematic experiment and mathematics.
Electricity is a good example.
At the beginning of the 18th century,
philosophers considered
it a straightforward
mechanical effect owing to streams
of small bits of ordinary matter
drawn forth from amber,
glass, and cats by friction.
These streams carried light small bodies
toward and away from the excited electric,
as the rubbed glass was called,
and so brought about what electricians
described as attractions and repulsions.
By allowing the electrical
matter to contain light,
electricians could also account
qualitatively for sparks and glows
like famous "Beatification" in which light
springs from the crown
of an electrified saint.
Toward 1750, electricians invented
the condenser which soon taught them
that the mechanical explanation
of electrical effects had fatal flaws.
Their teacher was Benjamin Franklin,
and he's teaching the doctrine
of plus and minus electricity.
By 1800, a model based on
the gravitational theory,
which is essentially the electrostatic
still taught in elementary physics,
had replaced the mechanical explanation.
The new model, different
from earlier physics
in two capital ways.
It was quantitative whereas
the theory of electrical streams
destroyed by Franklin was qualitative,
and it was causative,
whereas Newtonian
gravitation was descriptive.
The development in history,
parallel to Franklinist electricity,
was the combination of narrative
with its stress on motives and causes
with systemized antiquarian facts.
Perhaps it will be
enough to point to Gibbon
to indicate the type.
The great pageant of his
"Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire"
is powered by the
self-interest great persons
and the indifference of historical forces
and documented by appeal to artifacts
as well as to the written word.
In preparation for his visit to Italy
in 1764 during which he conceived
his grand project "Amid
the Ruins of the Forum",
Gibbon studied ancient Roman coins
and medals assiduously and worked his way
through Mabillon's diplomatics.
He was as well equipped
with antiquarian knowledge
when he crossed the Alps, he said,
as Hannibal's army was with elephants.
The art and science of
the decline and fall
lie in the use of antiquarian evidence
along with ancient and modern histories
and common sense motives to explain
the triumph of barbarism and religion
that ended the Roman Empire.
It seems to follow that
Gibbon's famous history
and a darling physical
science of the 18th century
are but two forms of the same thing.
The union of similar restraining
and enabling techniques
with bold assumptions of causes.
After analogies too strong to resist
brought me to recognize this odd parallel,
I found a golden passage in
Joseph Priestley's lectures
on History of 1788.
Priestley was the discoverer
of oxygen and other gasses.
Historian, teacher, philanthropist,
unitarian minister, Franklin's friend,
and as an exegete of the New Testament,
a forerunner of the higher critics.
The golden passage reads, quote,
"Real history resembles the experiments
"made by the electrical machine,
"the ground work and materials
"of the most extensive
and useful theories."
I come to time and space.
Newton accepted the mosaic account
of the literal truth,
though not the whole truth,
as the literal truth
though not the whole truth
about the creation and the flood
Delving as usual more deeply than others,
Newton perceived that Moses had hinted
at the Copernican system of the world
in the dumbed down account
he gave of the Big Bang in Genesis.
So, too, the unleashing of the waters
of the abyss that caused the flood
was not the whole story.
As Newton's disciple and
successor at Cambridge,
William Whiston showed the Earth drowned
as a result of passing
through a comet's tail.
You see this story up here on the left
with some additional information
I won't bother you with.
Whiston was one of
several savants in Britain
in the 1680s and 1690s who
worked out histories of the Earth
and the basis of scraps of scripture
and heaps of fossils.
They taught that the universal deluge
deposited the mineralized
remains of marine forms
sometimes found on mountain sides.
People with historical interest
often collected fossils
together with coins and
inscriptions as relics of antiquity.
The two lines of inquiry,
Earth and human history,
acted powerfully on one another.
Everyday observations suggested
that the Earth's surface had undergone
important changes in historical time.
Sediments once on the water
had been left high and dry.
Rivers had changed course.
Harbors had silted up.
Erosion, earthquakes, and floods
had accomplished wonders
over long periods of time.
To increase the available time
and the variety of effected
geophysical forces,
the date of creation had to
be pushed back indefinitely.
And to do that required demoting
the authority of scripture.
That was done most effectively
by humanistic considerations.
During the 1670s when Mabillon
and his group of Benedictines
worked on diplomatics in St. Maur,
the Orientalist Richard Simon
worried in his Oratorian convent
across the river how
to put his discoveries
about the Bible diplomatically.
Biological analysis of
the text had convinced him
that the Old Testament, as we have it,
was the work of many
hands over many centuries
that Moses could not have written it all
or perhaps any of it,
that its original version
may have been inspired
but none of its surviving text
met the test of coherence,
let alone of divinity.
The Hebrew Bible in its Greek translation
were such brilliant patchworks
that no modern critic could say for sure
which parts conveyed a divine message
and which were just good stories.
Simon developed these
opinions with the help
of a man whose ideas were of anything
more revolting than his.
This was Isaac de La Peyrère.
Simon met him in the Oratorian
convent outside Paris
to which Peyrère had retired
following an extraordinary journey
through the republic of letters.
In 1655, Peyrère had
published a scandalous book
arguing the existence of men
and especially women before Adam,
a proposition that save the Bible
from such difficulties of the origins
of the wives of Adam's sons,
and of the people for whose
information God branded Cain.
By admitting that the Old Testament
was at best the story of
the Jews, not of humankind,
historians could accept the claims
of the Chinese, Egyptians, and Americans
to an antiquity greater than 6,000 years
and avoid the problem
of the origins of people
at the periphery of Europe,
like the Greenlanders on whom Peyrère
perhaps modeled his pre-Adamites.
As for divine inspiration,
Peyrère observed
that Moses' description of affairs
that took place after his death
was evidence not of
revelation but of bad editing.
Peyrère's pre-Adamites
created a great sensation.
The general of the Jesuit order
and the Pope laughed together over it
until they joined in
ecumenical brotherhood
with the Jews, Calvinists and Lutherans
in anathematizing it.
Without much industry, theologians found
that it contained over 100 heresies.
The Catholics were the first
to lay hands on the culprit.
Peyrère's powerful friends who included
Queen Christina of Sweden
sprang him from jail
on condition that he go to Rome
and apologize to Christina's
friend, Pole Alexander VII,
who had chuckled with the Jesuit general,
and to convert to Catholicism.
And so he did.
After explaining the Calvinist
permissiveness of all things
that led him astray.
Alexander was so taken
with his unusual guest
that he offered him a
benefit to remain in Rome,
but Peyrère preferred to return to France
and to his job as a librarian.
He continued to talk of his pre-Adamites
using the subterfuge by which
the Jesuits, in his time,
taught the heliocentric astronomy
proscribed by the Holy Office.
To anyone who took
offense, he explained that
by Copernicus' system,
the theory of pre-Adamites
did not change the facts but
explained them more easily,
and that consequently in each case
only a pope could know for sure
that the belief was wrong.
Peyrère was a gentle scholar
and a very dangerous man.
Not only Simon but the
more redoutbable Espinoza
made use of his arguments.
During the 18th century,
the date of creation gradually receded
under reciprocating reinforcing blows
from biblical criticism and Earth history.
Among those who delivered the blows
were the first popularizer of Newton's
physics in France, its leading historian,
and his most effective opponent
of biblical literalism.
These three persons were
in fact but one, Voltaire.
Then there were the Comte de Buffon
who heedlessly helped themselves
to 75,000 years to allow for
the evolution of the Earth
and its population by living creatures.
Emmanuel Kant and others who derived
their solar system from
the coagulation of a nebula
over incalculable periods of time.
And Johann Gottfried Eichhorn,
Professor of Oriental Languages
at the University of Göttingen,
who treated the Old Testament as a choice
bit of oriental literature.
The situation around 1800 may be indicated
by the rear guard battles fought
by the celebrated Jean-André Deluc.
Who?
One of the most distinguished
natural philosophers
of the later 18th century.
Deluc was celebrated for his improvements
in meteorological instruments
and his descriptions
of the geology, a word he coined,
of Switzerland and Germany.
But he was also a strict
Genevan Calvinist.
The two qualifications made his career.
Queen Charlotte of England,
a true Blue Stocking
and a religious woman,
wanted someone to read to her in French
and to teach her natural science,
a philosopher but not a philosol.
Deluc got this position and retained it
for 43 years until his death in 1815,
evidently Charlotte was
not quick at physics.
He summed up his teachings
in five volumes of rambling,
letters on physics and ethics
aimed at establishing the reliability
of the Book of Genesis as
a report of human history.
He was too strict an empiricist, however,
to save the mosaic account of creation.
The flood had destroyed all evidence
of the early history of Earth and man.
Creation over six days was a metaphor
for creation over an extended period.
How long extended even
Deluc could not say.
Deluc's discovery that Moses' account
of the flood perfectly fit the facts
he had uncovered from
the alps to the hearts
was good news enough.
With support from Charlotte's husband
and America's benefactor, George III,
Deluc wandered through
Germany like a prophet.
He convinced people of his
generation, he was then 70,
but made little progress with younger folk
brought up on deism laxity
and the higher criticism.
On his way back to
England he heard a group
of young Brits discussing
religion in a very free manner.
They were completely ignorant
of the bearing of the
fossil record on the truth
of the universal deluge.
The queen's preceptor
could not hold his peace.
"Do you know who I am?"
They did not.
"I am Deluc."
They had never heard of him.
His time was up.
James Hutton, the Scott
who worked out a system
of geological transformations
involving only the sorts of forces
he saw at work around
him, had heard of Deluc.
They had argued over
the vast drafts of time
that Hutton required to shape the Earth.
"Time is to nature
endless and is nothing,"
Hutton wrote in 1788.
This squandering of time,
this prodigious wastefulness
was as bad at teaching as
deism to a Swiss prophet.
Deluc was inspired to ever
more powerful arguments,
but to no avail.
Hutton's system became
Lyle's, Darwin's, and ours.
The story of the enlargement of space
is more easily told.
By Deluc's time, the Copernican theory
was the common belief of educated people.
Catholic mathematicians
had taught it freely
since around 1730 when they discovered
the aberration of starlight
and its straightforward explanation
by the motions of the Earth and light
made the stationary
Earth almost untenable.
At mid century, Pope Benedict XIV
canceled the church's blanket proscription
against Copernican works,
although Galileo stayed on
the index for old time's sake.
By the end of the century,
telescopes with achromatic lenses
and exactly calibrated micrometers
were searching the sky
for stellar parallax,
still without success.
Their power of resolution
was a few seconds of arc,
hence, because the stars
showed no parallax,
the nearest of them had to be distanced
by at least 5 billion terrestrial radii,
about 250,000 times Ptolemy's estimate
of the size of the universe.
And since by then astronomers
knew that the stars
stood at different distances from the sun,
the universe had become
as indefinite in size
as with Hutton it was in age.
Thickening of knowledge.
We're not working on Atlantis
or building up the University of Uppsala.
Rudbeck was preparing to publish pictures
of every known species of
plant estimated at 7,000.
He'd completed one half his task
when in 1702 a dreadful fire in Uppsala
destroyed the wood blocks, plates
and drawings for the other half.
Lineas took up the work,
but the discoveries of microscopic plants,
a lot of these from Asia and America,
novel fungi, animal, plants
and plant-like animals
had quintupled the
estimated species count.
At the end of the 18th century,
another 40 years of exploring
by ship and microscope,
the estimate of the
number of plant species
had risen to 175,000.
But plants were few and easy
in comparison with insects.
John Ray, a naturalist
of the late 17th century,
mentioned as an indication
of divine creativity
that 2,000 insect species
lived in Britain alone,
and perhaps 20,000 elsewhere.
Half a century later in
1744, the estimate was 65,000
derived from raising a
number of plant species
to 13,000 and awarding
five species of insect
to each of them.
Or perhaps 130,000 since each insect
has another that feeds
upon it, or better 260,000
since naturalists had
explored only half the world.
Applying these the same calculation
to the late 18th century estimate
of 175,000 plants species
populated the world with 1,700,000
different kinds of insect.
How graspitall.
A Swedish naturalist tried.
He emerged 16 volumes later
having surveyed a few sorts of beetle.
The same thickening of knowledge
occurred in the historical
sciences and humanities,
a century that began with the invention
of archeology and ended
with that of anthropology
could scarcely keep track
of books and the (mumbles).
Already in the 17th century,
the auxiliary sciences of
history were getting out of hand.
Jean Tristan, a minor aristocrat
but a major collector published a history
of the Roman emperors illustrated
by coins and medals from
his own collections.
He required three volumes containing
well over a million words.
He spared one of them for colleagues
who thought they could get by with fewer,
a word with jackass.
Mabillon's successor, Bernard
de Montfaucon was no jackass
but he had to admit that
even after 20 years of study
he could not master all the writings
of prolix addicts like Tristan.
He therefore undertook to sift
and synthesize for students
willing to devote two years of hard work
to learning Greco-Roman antiquities.
His epitome, his brief
text of the central matters
ran to five volumes in folio
which he immediately had to
supplement with another five.
And Greek and Roman antiquities
made up a dwindling fraction
of items of antiquarian interest
accumulated in the 17th
and 18th centuries.
Students of the Middle Ages found things
everywhere they looked.
Sometimes their productivity
was breathtaking.
Thomas Hern, an accurate
and dislikeable scholar,
published a volume of medieval manuscripts
every three or four
months when in good form
or rather in bad form.
And a colleague, an older colleague of his
described his condition and I quote,
"A great alteration was made in him.
"His acquaintance took notice
"of the falling away of his body,
"the fading of his cheeks.
"Yet he was very cheerful,
contented and helpful,
"nothing troubled him more
"than the intermission of his labors
"by drinking, sleeping, and sometimes
"by company he could not avoid."
Historians have their
exemplary heroes, too.
Yesterday I gave Anglo-Saxon studies
in his example of the widespread activity
of English antiquaries.
But despite the Herns
and the Anglo-Saxons,
Britain was not holding its own
in a deluge of medieval documents,
or so Gibbons said,
lamenting that his country
had not produced a Muratori
who single-handedly
published all the histories
of Italy known to him written
between 500 and 1500 AD.
Then there were German, Franks, Celtic,
old Icelandic and Slovanik collections
in the great mass of
ethnographical material
brought back by Jesuit
and other missionaries.
It remained only to
collect the collectors.
I do not believe that I mentioned
the appetite of the enlightenment
for universal history.
I have time only to
gesture that at 64 volumes
of an universal history from
the earliest account of time
to the present compiled
from original authors
which Gibbon, when a boy,
read as they came out
as if they were the
adventures of Harry Potter.
And universal history went
through several English,
five Italian, and two French editions,
and one in German, much
improved by his translators
between 1740 and 1800.
Its first part devoted to ancient history
did not break entirely from
traditional sacred history,
although to undermine its fidelity
by offering 98 choices
for the date of creation.
As polyglot authors were far
from establishment characters,
and they did not falsify their accounts
to agree with the budget of Bishop Ussher.
The modern part of the universal history
gives all existing
peoples and civilizations
a history, though to be sure,
from a British point of view.
The enlightenment invented ways
to index if not to grasp or curb
this scholarly productivity.
It invented the review journal
and the encyclopedia,
and towards the end a specialized index
of the papers presented
to learned societies
which multiply almost as fast as insects.
The famous "Encyclopédie"
of Diderot and d'Alembert
required 28 large
volumes, 71,818 articles,
and 2,885 plates to do justice,
or as many thought injustice,
to the knowledge of the mid-18th century.
But they were in different compilers
compared by Johann Heinrich Zedler
who completed his "Grosses
vollständiges Universal-Lexicon"
in 64 volumes just as the
"Encyclopédie" began to appear.
As you see, Zedler's work
made for easy reading.
(audience laughing)
The arrival of the "Encyclopédie"
did not discourage him.
He plowed on with a supplement
that would have reached 50 volumes
had Zedler not departed this life
in the middle of the letter C.
Just before 1800, Eichhorn,
the higher critic,
paused from his impious labors,
contemplated the swollen
learning of his day,
decided that it marked
an epoch in civilization
and determined to celebrate
and document all of it.
He rounded up professors from Göttingen
and in a few other German universities
to write the histories
of their disciplines
from the revival of
learning in the 13th century
to the end of the 18th century.
The series reached 57 volumes.
The history of history in two volumes
opens with the gratifying information
that everywhere in Europe,
people were studying
history as never before.
Enlightened rulers,
bureaucrats, merchants,
professional men, scholars and students.
The very great activity in the field
of historical literature, its author
Johann Friedrich Ludwig Wachler concluded,
is an unmistakable
characteristic of our time.
There were the sort of
differences you might expect
among the history producing nations,
the French historians being
elegant and political,
the English enthusiastic
but only about England,
the German's vigorous
polyglot and thorough.
But on the whole, in Wachler's opinion,
historical writing in Europe
made up a consistent unity.
That was because, he said,
it incorporated so much
from other sciences:
chronology, astronomy,
and geography of course
but also philosophy,
psychology, anthropology,
linguistics, ethnology,
numismatics, diplomatics and archeology.
History was an important
subject in Eichhorn's Göttingen
entirely liberated from
his old subservience
to law and theology.
It was universal and cultural,
as well as geographical coverage.
Besides professorial chairs
in history, the university
had an historical institute
and probably the best stocked
and most readily accessible collection
of historical books in Europe.
The founder/director of
the historical institute,
Johann Christoph Gatterer,
who helped promote
the German translation of the
English universal history,
kept a careful meteorological journal
from which he worked out relations
between human history, the weather,
and solar/lunar and geographical data.
A once living symbol of the
ties between the physical
and historical sciences at Göttingen
in the late 18th century
was its first woman PhD,
Dorothea Schlözer.
As a child, she mastered universal history
in the several volumes that her father,
one of Göttingen's leading historians,
wrote for her and also 10 languages.
She is shown here reading a
book on physico-mathematics.
You'll have to take my word for it.
The natural sciences
covered in Eichhorn's series
were mathematics in four volumes,
which would've been many more
if their author had not died
before he reached the
invention of the calculus,
chemistry in three volumes
and physics in eight.
Eight volumes.
This last performance was
only a little excessive
for it could be said of physics
as Wachler said of history
that the very great activity in it
was an unmistakable
characteristic of its time.
Still the longest and most detailed
history of physics ever written.
Johann Karl Fischer's
Geschichte der Physik
contains much the physicists today
would recognize as their subject matter.
I doubt, however, that they
would accept his emphases.
He cited Deluc or often
than Galileo or Huygens.
He did so because he
believed that Deluc's topics,
electricity, heat, meteorology,
pneumatics, geophysics,
had not yet acquired firm foundations.
In dealing with them,
Fischer could not play
the Whig historian, that is write history
from the standpoint of the victor
because he did not know
whose contributions
would prove fundamental.
Therefore, he included
much that modern science
would consider trivial or wrong.
"The History and Present
State of Electricity"
by Joseph Priestley, published
in his definitive form
in 1775, was another such compendium.
It is written from a close
examination of the sources
with quotations and exact citations
just as if it were ecclesiastical history.
Priestley's analysis of
the historical evidence
for the doctrine of the
Immaculate Conception
has exactly the form of
his analysis of experiments
relative to the equally
undecidable question
of the number of electrical fluids.
In both cases, the historical approach
to the current state of science
had the advantage over the deductive
in allowing the presentation
of all the facts
in their original setting,
however contradictory
they might appear so that
nothing that might prove to be,
that might point to the
ultimate answer was omitted.
The generation that
followed the professors
who wrote for Eichhorn's series
managed to reach provisional agreement
on many subject left open in the confusion
of facts and interpretations
put forward by Deluc and many others.
Johann Tobias Mayer, who
became professor of physics
at Göttingen in the early 19th century,
shared the new consensus
on physical principles
and explicitly disavowed
the historical method
as confusing to beginners
and generally useless.
But in fields in which
conflicting opinions
about fundamentals
reigned, he employed it.
Thus, he had recourse
to the method of history
in present state in his
text book on meteorology.
We may take it as
symbolic as well as pious
that he began his coverage
with the meteorological studies
by then 40 years old
of Göttingen's deceased
former professor of
history, Johann Gatterer.
I don't lament the time when
a professor of natural science
could take off a year or more
to write the history of his discipline
and when historians were as good
at meteorology as physicists.
But what I do regret is that physicists
and historians,
technoscientists and humanists
now do not know much
about how knowledge was
and is created in the others' domain
or how their several disciplines advanced
by similar steps.
That is not good for the institution
that nourishes them both, the university.
I don't pretend that there
ever was a perfect balance
between the natural
sciences and the humanities
in the university.
Through most of the 19th century,
history and the humanities dominated.
And since World War II, the sciences,
and engineering, have done so.
Some people see this
ongoing process as a contest
between purity and prostitution
to use terms flung
about during discussions
of the BP project last spring.
By which I suppose they meant a contest
between research undertaken
for no particular reason
and research aimed at
utilitarian objectives.
In these lectures, I've tried to show
that the most basic of
humanities, history,
and the most basic of sciences, physics
advanced together in early modern times
in large part, owing to
pressures to made them useful
to the wider society.
As university studies, they
try to distance themselves
from these pressures.
Which, however, eventually
pushed some of them
towards social sciences and
others toward engineering.
One of the great challenges
of research universities today
is to find a proper balance
among the disciplines
in an environment in which
faculty and administration
constantly search for money.
In seeking the balance, we must be aware
of placing too strong on emphasis
on utilitarian objectives.
Among other dangers,
it encourages a subtle
but potent feedback mechanism.
University graduates,
ignorant of the place
and function of the
humanities in our society,
are unlikely to want to support them
through taxes or philanthropy.
Decline in social support
translate into loss of prestige
inside as well as outside the university.
Weakness confirms irrelevance.
And the next generation of graduates
has less interest in
supporting the humanities
than its predecessor.
This feedback may have been operating
in our country for some time.
To mention but one indicator, the budget
of the National Endowment
for the Humanities
was cut in half in the 1890s
and curtailed again in the 1990s.
It has not recovered.
In real terms, the endowment has about 40%
of what it had in 1980.
Of course there are many sources
of funding for the humanities
besides the federal government.
However, the great cuts
in government funding
over the last 30 years
may be taken as a hint
at the value assigned to
humanities in our society.
The situation might be ameliorated
by an approach devised
by James Bryant Conant,
one of the prime movers
in the mobilization
of scientific manpower for World War II.
As president of Harvard, he undertook
to ensure that the
public would do its duty
and support science after the war
as it had never been
supported in peacetime before.
Conant proposed to
educate the future leaders
of the nation, that is Harvard graduate,
in what he called the tactics
and strategy of science.
He had in mind the methods and standards
of scientific inquiry and
the need for lots of money
to advance the research front.
We might consider doing
something similar but cleverer
to make all Berkeley undergraduates aware
of the intellectual strength
and cultural importance
of the humanities, and
history of course included,
so that when they take
their rightful place
ahead of Harvard's graduates
among the leaders of the nation
they will work to reverse the trend
represented by the continuing
underfunding of the NEH.
Such a course could promote
respect for what deserved
and an informed critical
attitude toward the rest.
That is the intellectual good taste
described at such length by
Maria Torre 200 years ago.
The course might help to diminish
a type of segregation on the campus,
more difficult to overcome
than any that may exist
between people of different color.
Segregation between the
humanities and the sciences.
If this segregation exist at Berkeley,
a course of the type
proposed might be subsumed
in the American culture's requirement.
There is no reason to limit
the course to undergraduates.
The rhetoric in the BP debate
that reminds me of the
compliments exchanged
between flakiest Baronio suggest
that some faculty members
and administrators also could
profit from exposure to it.
We may well stand at the
threshold of the development
of worldwide importance.
Does it not make a good opportunity
to renew the old partnership
and refresh the feeling of mutual respect
which existed when science and history
once before worked together
to change a dysfunctional world view.
If Berkeley's energy
initiatives are to make history,
as the chancellor and the
director of LBL expect
and no doubt most of us hope,
the project should
include some historians.
In their different ways,
scientists and historians
both make history.
But the historians will
always have the last word.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- [Participant] My question was about,
I guess maybe causation as
distinct from correlation,
that is these parallel
stories that you were telling.
To what degree are they parallel
and where do they engage with one another?
I heard a common cause in
the pressure to be useful,
but what other sort of either, yeah,
what other common causes are there
or moments where they
are actually connected
as opposed to just parallel?
- You see, I have nurtured a viper.
Professor Riskin is a student of mine.
Furthermore, she teaches at Stanford.
(audience laughing)
So perhaps you will excuse me (chuckles),
well, I have to answer to
try to answer the question.
It's a very good question of course.
Correlation, parallels,
analogies are not proofs;
they're merely suggestive
of further parallels,
correlations and analogies
which I have tried to draw out perhaps
at too great an extent.
But if one looks for common causes
besides all of the usual ones
for the beginning of
modernity, as I mentioned
at the beginning of my lecture last time
and tries to get down into more detail.
Then one looks at the
intellectual trajectories
of various actors and then you find a mix,
a mix of motives as to
why they were able to work
in both history and in science.
But I don't know what I can
say that is more than pointing
to the very big forces
which we all recognize.
Now you can get into
somewhat greater detail.
For example, the Protestant
Reformation is trotted out
as a fourth cause for the
development of modern science
because of some supposed parallel
between the Protestant virtues
and the qualities supposed
necessary to advance science
like sobriety and
investment in the operation
and industry and that sort of thing.
And of course on the other
hand from my lecture last time,
you will remember that the
efforts of the Protestants
to trace their ancestry,
to trace Luther back
to the early church did
inspire investigations
into the church history
in the medieval documents
which proved important for the development
of historical writing.
So I would pursue it in that direction
and I would be very happy
if you would join me.
(audience laughing)
- People with some scientific background
are very puzzled by, in a way the picture
you painted of Isaac Newton,
and I'm wondering whether
you could say a little more
to explain or to some extent this,
his energies that were poured into,
the energy he poured into studies
that seem to demand tremendous credulity
when he was making these
fantastic other descriptions.
I find it completely incomprehensible,
the amount of energy
he spent at Cambridge.
In these studies that you alluded to,
could you say a little
more to make it credible?
- Well, I think Newton
thought himself a prophet
and he took all knowledge as his sphere
and was trying to recover
what the ancients knew.
And he felt that certain ancient texts
required his particular study,
mainly, or among others,
the prophecies of Daniel.
And he spent a lot of
time trying to identify
events subsequent to the
prophecy that did occur
with their prophetic description.
That was part of his self
image and to employ an analogy.
From science, you have the quantum Newton.
You cannot have Newton,
the world system builder,
the mathematician, the
towering mathematician,
without Newton the prophet.
Because they come together,
they are responding
to the same set of problems
of the time in which he lived.
And so for me, it's a puzzle indeed
to think that a man had the energy
to devote himself with such ferocity
to so wide a range of subjects.
But I'm not surprised at all that a mind,
as capacious as his, would
have wished at that time
to undertake such studies.
I decline the terms of the question
insofar as it implies that we could've had
Newton or the Principia without Newton
of the prophecies of Daniels
or the ancient kingdoms amended.
(calm music)